des images de trois rivières où le
candidat à la chefferie du parti
conservateur pierre poilievre avec son
épouse est venu s'adresser à des
militants il est avec nous pendant qu'on
voit l'ancien maire de trois-rivières
jeu l'éveil qui est un de vos un de ceux
qui vous appuyez monsieur poirier
bonsoir bonsoir vous avez deux trois
jours au québec commencent à votre
campagne au québec parce qu'on
nom ne dit que monsieur charest avait
beaucoup beaucoup d'appuis est-ce que
vous commencez à sentir que vous avez
des appuis aussi mais on a eu des grands
rassemblements ici à montréal hier à
trois-rivières à québec on avec 250
personnes très enthousiaste alors ma
message de liberté et chèque de paie à
fonctionne très bien ici au québec les
gens veulent reprendre le contrôle de
leur vie avec en vendant le canada le
pays le plus libre au monde en même
temps il veut une candidat qui peut
contrer l'inflation qui a causé le
gouvernement pour protéger la valeur de
leur chèque de paie et leur pouvoir
d'achat on va on va parler de tout ça
mais sur toile et première question si
vous aviez été premier ministre
est-ce que les camions seraient encore
devant le parlement à terme en ont les
conflits les camions n'aurait jamais été
devant le parlement lundi sont brûlés
mais pour les raisons pour laquelle il
était là c'était parce que justin
trudeau a créé une obligation vaccinale
pour eux deux ans après les camionneurs
était en train de livrer nos produits et
nos services en traversant la frontière
sans vaccin et on les appelait les héros
mais soudainement justin trudeau a
décidé au bon moment que les autres pays
enlevé ses obligations de les imposer
sur les mêmes gens qui sans le peler les
moins probables de ce décès mais une
virus les gens qui travaillent seuls
dans un camion vingt quatre heures par
jour 6 alors je sais que je peux pleurer
on était donc j'aurai jamais les
attaques et donc il n'y aurait jamais eu
une manifestation
premier ministre encore une fois ci la
santé publique vous aurais dit il faut
imposer son kamenar il faut et avec
d'autres mesurés mais est ce que vous
écoutez auriez la santé publique qui
vous dit on doit faire telle ou telle
mesure oui mais non partisan en fait
madame camara était dans le docteur
thème on lui a demandé espiet de
sciences pour appuyer une obligation de
vaccins pour les gens dans un camion
vingt quatre heures par jour seul homme
elle a dit il n'y a vraiment pas de
preuves pour montrer que senna sur serre
ni efficace alors il n'y avait pas de
six ans en arrière ça c'était juste une
attaque contre la classe ouvrière une
attaque contre les gens qui ont mort
livrer nos produits et nos services etc
tel un zoo les sens pour laquelle j'ai
appuyé alors leurs efforts de protéger
leur liberté et leur chèque de paie et
ça vous inquiète pas de voir pierre
poilievre que c'était financé par
certains groupes d'extrême droite aux
états unis que les gens n'ont absolument
pas respecté la loi et l'ordre que vous
prônez pourtant mais j'ai dit 'de même
avant l'arrivée de ces camionneurs on
m'a demandé est ce que j'allais appuyé
ça j'ai dit je vais appuyer la cause des
gens qui veut protéger leurs chèques tu
paies et leur liberté et qui se
comportent bien tout encore des noms des
individus
qui se comportent mal ou qui brise la
loi ou coup qui a fait des blocages de
l'infrastructure essentielle et c'est
exactement ce que j'ai répété pendant
toutes les périodes c'est exactement ce
que j'ai dit pendant tous les
manifestations qu'on a bu mais met donc
j'ai pas un grand fan des mesures
sanitaires dont ceux comme ça mais à
découvrir si la santé publique dit un
gouvernement que ce soit au québec en
ontario ottawa vous devriez exiger telle
chose est ce que vous seriez d'accord ou
vous diriez non je vous écoute pas donc
j'ai que j'écouterais dès la séance mais
c'est le problème c'est que justin
trudeau on n'écoute pas les séances
maintenant il est en train de garder en
place ces obligations même quand le
reste le monde est en train de les aider
de les enlever il n'y a aucune raison
pour laquelle on devrait mieux garder en
place ces mesures qui attaque les
libertés des gens qui causent le dit la
dépression parmi les jeunes qui sont
isolés de leurs activités physiques et
leurs amis
un thé publics ne disposent que vous non
non non non non c'est pas vrai
maintenant on est allé pro copieux plus
loin que ce que la sanction si nous dit
demande et m c'est la raison pour
laquelle on voit les provinces qui sont
en train d'enlever ces mesures
sanitaires mais justin trudeau va
continuer parce qu' il aime le pouvoir
il aime le pouvoir que la pandémie lui a
donné en fait c'est pas moi qui dis ça
c'est joe haldeman son propre député
libéral qui a dit que justin trudeau
l'utilisent pour diviser les gens et le
prendre le pouvoir je suis d'accord avec
le libéral joël est pas la tuer au gros
de la cinquième de la 5ème courbe est ce
que vous auriez été d'accord pour dire
aux gens vous allez vous priver de
liberté
c'est ça la question
ni dernier janvier dernier cassez s'est
remis à remonter yaya au début il y
avait une raison pour avoir des mesures
sanitaires c'est sûr mais après du temps
c'est clair que ce n'est pas de science
qui a guidé les politiciens surtout au
niveau fédéral c'était le pouvoir le et
madame frilet notter libéral a dit que
cela coville était une opportunité
politique et c'est comme ça que les
libéraux l'ont vu c'est exactement ce
que monsieur layton a dit qu ont ils
accusé son propre premier nice ne sont
pas propres parti d'utiliser le collègue
comme un outil politique pour diviser
les canadiens je suis contre ça je suis
pour la liberté déjà vous êtes un
bataillon xaviera
politique depuis le début on vous suit
on a l'impression parfois que vous vous
présentez comme le seul conservateur de
tous ces gens là de tous les candidats
ce char et libérale vous dites monsieur
brand nous détaillerons peut pas
l'écouter il ya aussi les taxes
également taxe carbone etc etes-vous le
seul vrai conservateur non je dirais pas
ça j'ai beaucoup de respect pour madame
l'islande ou est ce qui est vrai
conservatrices très très qualifiés une
bonne très très bonne personne mais oui
je suis un batailleur et lesquin les
canadiens ont besoin d'un batailleur le
jeune homme de 32 ans qui me conduit
dans le sous-sol de sa mère parce que
les pays épris du mobilier ont doublé en
cinq ans il a besoin d'un batailleur
pour lui la perse les personnes âgées
qui paient trop pour la nourriture qui
peut pas qu'ils puissent qui sont parmi
les quatre sur cinq familles qui ont dû
réduire au régime alimentaire à cause
des coûts de leur nourriture ils ont
besoin d'un batailleur le travailleur
qui ne peut pas payer le feu les
factures de l'essence il a besoin d'un
de batailleur coop et c'est moi qui va
contrer l'inflation que justin trudeau a
causé et et ça prend une bataille on
pour le char est un libéral boutisme un
conservateur et il était libéral pas
juste ce n'est pas juste le marque de
commerce et ses politiques il a monté le
taxe de vente ici au québec deux fois il
a ajouté une taxe un autre taxe sur
l'essence et une taxe carbone il veut
cibler les chasseurs et les acryliques
les fermiers au lieu des vrais criminels
ce sont des politiques et des petits
partis libéral moi je suis conservateur
je veux réduire des taxes rendre le
public plus abordable et contrer
l'inflation l'inflation
qu'est ce que vous faites avec les taxes
sur l'essence on les enlève on lui fait
on les baisse je crois on va les
minéraux mais ont premièrement je vais
éliminer le taxe carbone pour réduire le
prix de l'essence et ça va réduire aussi
le coup de nourriture et de chauffage
parce que le taxe augmente le prix de
tout
deuxièmement je mettrais bien faire
cette pratique d'imprimer l'argent pour
financer les déficits exorbitantes quand
on est prêt à jouer le à oman et âme et
sans ajouter aux productions des biens
et services allemands toujours le coup
plus dedans alors qu'ils achètent moins
de services augmentent les coûts sont
que je vais arrêter l'impression de
l'argent pour protéger le valeur de
notre monnaie et rentre là les chèques
de paie plus puissants ou vous coupez
pas ce que vous voulez arriver plus
jette un déficit zéro vous couper ou par
exemple le 6 milliards que le
gouvernement fédéral envoie au québec
pour les garderies vous couper ça on
verra qu'à me combien il crie ça
fonctionne parce que maintenant on n'a
vu aucune résultats les libéraux ont
dépensé ils ont promis de des garderies
abordable depuis 30 ans mais encore
depuis six ans un pouvoir et on n'a pas
le pouvoir n'a pas vu des résultats
alors si ça marche ici rsa réduit à
bédée coup de garderie moi je suis pour
ça mais si on dépense je sais
aussi qu'on n'obtient pas des résultats
comme auparavant les libéraux ont
dépensé des milliards et des milliards
en disant que ça allait réduire veto de
l'aider des frais de bd garderie mais on
n'a rien vu en terme de résultat après
tous ces dépenses là les garderai cent
plus cher que je mets moi je vais mettre
l'argent directement dans les poches de
monsieur et madame tout le monde et par
an je comprends mais l'entente de 6
milliards vous l'a maintenu ou pas on
verra si ça fonctionne si sa livre des
résultats maintenant on a vu que les
libéraux ont fait beaucoup de promesses
par rapport au chaos au coût des
garderies mais ils ont dépensé sur la
bureaucratie sans aucune résultats pour
les parents moi j'aimerais mettre
l'argent de la poche des parents et non
pas les politiciens pipeline ce char et
en parle aussi vous en parler est ce que
vous pourriez utiliser le pouvoir
fédéral qui existent d'imposer un
pipeline vers l'est donc sur l'ontario
sur le québec mais il n'y a pas une
telle proposition maintenant mais je
vais vous dire très très ouvertement
j'étais pour nrj est et on air on serait
dans une meilleure position aujourd'hui
en europe avec la russie si on avait
énergie est qui aurait transporté 1
million de baril de louer de l'ouest
canadiennes vers l'est canadienne pour
les pour l'exporter à au pays
démocratique maintenant à cause du fait
qu'on a tué sept projets on voit que
l'europe dépendre sur poutine et
d'autres dictateurs le choix n'est pas
pétrole ou pas de pétrole le bloc et les
libéraux sont pour le pétrole étrangères
moi je suis pour l'énergie canadienne et
les québécois sont d'accord avec moi les
sondages plusieurs reprises ont montré
que les québécois si on doit utiliser le
projet du poids mais il ya trois choix
il faut choisir choisir entre le pétrole
étrangères les pétroles et canadiennes
je trouve je choisirai les travailleurs
canadiennes chaque fois ci un projet
mais nrj s2 vous imposer le pipeline mai
je pense que les québécois appuient rend
tous les projets pour aider
l'indépendance énergétique du canada et
je travaillais en collaboration avec eux
pour pour favoriser des projets des
pôles la production de notre énergie et
nos ressources et parlons d'imposer qui
a demandé aucun québécois la permission
d'avoir ses importations de pétrole
étrangères personne ne leur demandez ça
justin trudeau linteau sans le
consentement des québécois mais si un
projet est une province y reposent vous
verrez le droit non mais parce que le
fédéral vous avez ce droit leur faut
être clair avant pendant après est ce
que vous pourriez l'imposer je vais vous
me demandez de 2,2 me prononcer sur un
projet qui n'existe actuellement pas jeu
évidemment je dois voir une projet avant
de 10,2 prononcer sur le projet mais je
vais dire le principe c'est que j'y suis
je pense que les oléoducs les gazoducs
sont les maires et ce façon de
transporter l'énergie c'est le plus
sécuritaire l'énergie canadienne est
beaucoup mieux d'importer l'énergie
étrangères et les québécois en sont
d'accord
maxime bernier at-il une place à votre
dans votre parti dont il a choisi de
quitter le parti ils veulent pas être
les un conservateur vous voulez abolir
cilicie donc radio canada
pourquoi pourquoi pas avoir une vie
république aucun avis je vois la
différence entre cbi six anglais est ici
à l'abbaye et je vais expliquer pourquoi
moi ma philosophie le principe c'est que
le gouvernement devrait faire que les
choses que le marché et les gens ne
peuvent pas faire par eux mêmes ce que
cbc anglais fait c'est déjà fait c'est
dispo né près tous les informations
qu'on reçoit de cbc en anglais est déjà
dispo n'est par d autres à d autres
médias ham même leur couverture de
washington ils font que répéter cnnc des
mêmes suivant il mentionne même pas
l'existence du canada même si on dit que
c'est pour protéger l'identité
canadienne lors que radio canada
je reconnais que le marché ne fournit
pas tous les nouvelles et tout cette
culture et information en français parce
que nous vivons est évidemment dans un
aussillon
de l'anglais en amérique du nord alors
c'est facile pour le marché a livré sa
il n'ya pas aussi eu autant de 2010 a
donc concrètement en très grand maman
mais mes propositions là dessus seront
claires mais je veux juste vous dire que
le principe c'est que oui je comprends
qu'il ya une besoin dans la langue
française qui n'existait pas dans la
langue anglaise à en termes de médias
pierre poilievre on voit suivre cette
course absolument qui risque d'être
festive nantes au leadership
conservateur merci merci de m'avoir
invité au revoir à presser pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit